uh
so just because i brought up eric and uh
you're on twitter i'd love to hear your
opinions
okay i talked to him a lot he seems to
have stepped into the beautiful dance
of human communication and the social
dynamics that is the bitcoin
cryptocurrency community
do you have uh do you have thoughts on
uh
uh engaged theoretic concepts
conceptualization of the world or just
eric in general
he's got a lot of love in his heart and
he's got grace in the way he
communicates
but he's also loves to play with ideas
and seems to have touched a sensitive
point with the bitcoin community is
there anything you could say
uh that's hopeful inspiring about that
whole dynamic that went down
i so i don't know all of the details um
but what i will say is
i've listened to a number of his
podcasts um and
him and there's a whole bunch of people
like him i basically put them in the
bucket of they're an independent thinker
who are courageous enough to speak their
truth whatever that may be they are
humble enough to revisit their ideas
and say i got this right i got this
wrong information changed i'll change my
mind
it's obviously a sign of intelligence to
be able to do that type of stuff
and i actually think that one of the
most scarce things in our society are
those independent thinkers who are able
to do all this
right speaking of scarcity yeah and so
to me
uh i put eric and the whole host of
other people kind of
uh if you look at like the intellectual
dark web is kind of a label that's uh
been used
they're actually some of the most
important people in our society
because they're the people who are
willing to stand up against the mass
kind of um thought process they're
willing to
talk about things that others may think
are taboo right they're willing to
change their mind which all of a sudden
has become a bad thing rather than a
good thing
and so when i see the exploration of
ideas in public
i actually think that those are the
people who are most open
to the kind of vehement blowback as well
right
because that's part of what they're
doing is that they're eliciting hey i'm
going to throw an idea into the arena
if it doesn't get attacked they actually
may be more nervous than if there is
some level of you know kind of war of
attrition if you will
and so what i've seen with a number of
the people who have done this everyone
from
some of the best you know hedge fund
managers and kind of money managers in
the world
all the way to what i'll consider some
of the most uh intellectual people in
the world
is they play with these ideas and they
play with the ideas and they play with
them and they play them
and they all arrive at the same
conclusion and sometimes it takes a
month sometimes it takes years
but they arrive at this bitcoin thesis
and what's so interesting about it
is it highlights something that many
people view as a
bug but i think people in the bitcoin
community view as a feature
which is that community and so what ends
up happening is
when you have something that is as
ambitious as
creating a global reserve currency
doesn't mean it needs to unseat any of
the existing ones but become the global
reserve currency of the internet right
this digital economy
you need shepherds of it and so just
like a technology company wants to find
those loyal fans that are willing to go
out and market and
word of mouth and and kind of not only
uh promote it but also
uh protect it this technology that is
this decentralized thing
which uses a financial incentive in
order to
elicit the buy-in not from a financial
perspective but from a mental
energy standpoint has built one of the
most
rabid powerful and engaged communities
on the internet
and what ends up happening is those
people have thought more about these
ideas
and actually challenged those ideas more
than anyone else in the world
and so i've got a lot of folks who will
just say there's a guy marty bent who
we'll talk all the time about
the bitcoin critics haven't done their
homework in a lot of cases
so they show up and sometimes it's super
intellectual lazy arguments sometimes
it's actually very well thought out
arguments you know on the counter to the
bitcoin thesis
but ultimately what ends up happening is
you're talking to somebody who's
an expert i've been thinking about for
five seven eight ten years right they've
gone through every simulation you
possibly can
and they show up with data examples um
and responses now they're not always
right but they've just done the work and
so what i actually
uh like about folks like eric and others
is as they're kind of going through this
journey
they're incredibly smart right and they
provide
or they um apply a lot of intellectual
rigor
to some of these arguments and so what
it does is what does it do it's a
marketplace
it keeps people honest so i uh let me
sort of make a few comments it's kind of
interesting
so you're exactly right uh maybe the
blowback is part of the mechanism that
actually develops these ideas and so on
i do want to kind of speak to a little
bit of the toxicity that i've
experienced in the bitcoin community i
kind of see it
the bitcoin community i think he paints
a really nice picture which i kind of
see it as an immune system
that protects against sort of uh the
viruses
that are bad ideas that said the immune
system
can destroy a body right and
the thing you mentioned about eric and
maybe about myself
and in general just people exploring
ideas
is there is a dunning-kruger effect
which is when you first
start exploring ideas deeply you have
um overblown level of confidence about
like how much you understand
and that's actually the process about
learning then you realize you don't
understand much
what i've noticed with the bitcoin
community is uh
they're not as uh patient with the
the basics of the dunning-kruger effect
like if i step in
and make declarative statements about
bitcoin like i you know i read a long
time ago uh the white paper like
at the cursed degree level i felt uh
that
i understand the technology this is the
basic intuitions
you know i didn't think about the social
dynamics i didn't think about any like
financial
implications and a lot of the deep
actually the ongoing innovations and all
that kind of stuff
but i thought i understood that
technology and so i step in and make
declarative statements i think those are
the
the first time you say okay what's the
role of bitcoin in the world you start
thinking about it deeply
and then you make statements the
toxicity that you get
in those first few statements is really
off-putting to me i'm somebody that
tries to communicate love and
live that with everything i do and
there is a level of disrespect that i've
experienced
not directly just observing others
people have been mostly kind to me
and i appreciate that but if you're
going to criticize me
about my exploration of ideas in bitcoin
you have to also acknowledge that i'm a
human being that got like a phd
and stuff like i did some hard that
it could be in farming or it could be in
whatever
like i've lived life and i've really
thought deeply i really care
like i know a lot of and it's
possible
that i actually have a lot of ideas that
you can learn from
now if it's agriculture fine or if it's
artificial intelligence fine
like i know what i'm talking about about
certain things and i could be wrong
about a lot of things and there's like
an exchange of ideas that's
that makes the that mechanism that you
talked about
um more efficient sometimes when the
blowback is too strong
too early on the development of ideas is
just
inefficient and i'm not sure if if
there's a
you know the way it was explained to me
is that for so long
that community was like bombarded
with just like bad ideas like criticisms
they're just
overly sensitive now to like
to just they're like triggered
by statements
like they've heard it all before and
they're like oh there they go again with
the same old arguments
but that doesn't mean that um you know
you have to sort of i guess develop
patience and so on
especially when you feel like in my case
that the person is coming from a good
place right
i don't know if there's something you
could say yeah that's positive about the
future of this kind of overcoming this
toxicity
i think there's a couple of trends that
are all kind of coalescing here right
in these types of experiences so one is
uh when you look at a community
there's always um a spectrum right in
terms of
there's some people who over index on
kindness uh and stupidity
right and there's some people who over
index on intelligence and uh basically
just being an
right and then you get everyone in
between and so like uh
naturally as we know the extremist ends
of
any community end up being the loudest
usually right
the second thing is um
there is from the outsider view like in
at the beginning of the exploration of
ideas uh it's very much a learning
process
right it's it's i don't know if i
understand this or not but peers ideas a
b and c
from the internal perspective there's a
trillion dollars of value at stake and
we must protect it with our lives yeah
right the truth is probably somewhere in
between there right and
again the world's not black and white
there's there's kind of more gray area
that i think actually
um is where most people exist the other
thing that's at play here
is uh i think the bitcoin community
understands the internet and internet
culture
and uh narratives better than almost
anyone yes
and so you see this with kind of the uh
the just complete destruction
uh of narratives with memes and and um
just the the visceral reaction and the
use of things like
reddit and twitter and uh youtube
podcasts just
areas where um i think a lot about uh
if you are an upstart right and you are
going to go
challenge the most uh well-respected
elite uh kind of establishment
institutions in the world
if you walk in in a suit and tie and you
say
i'm here to debate you with ideas you're
going to get
your clock cleaned yeah right because
they're going to trot out
their lawyers their regulators their
lobbyists right like all this stuff
if you instead say i'm going to meme you
to death on the internet yeah and i'm
going to control the public narrative
you you've shifted the the power the
asymmetry of power is more symmetrical
now it's the ultimate insurgency
yeah right if you bring it back to the
the field
yes and so when you think about this you
have to lean into the advantage that you
have
yeah and so what ends up happening is
you and i
would absolutely lose it if we saw
jp morgan or goldman sachs or the
federal reserve
start tweeting memes yeah right it would
almost the
the validation it would give to the
medium and
the uh even playing field that it would
provide
would pull these establishments down
to the level of what is this upstart
but now what you're starting to see is
that the bitcoin community
even though there's some level of toxic
toxicity at times
even though there's this visceral
reaction sometimes there's even
what i would call bullying or or
kind of outward projection of things
right even though it may be a small
percentage it'll happen every once in a
while
what they do understand though is that
these establishments
are made up of humans and what you can
actually do one of the best ways to pick
apart an institution
is to recruit from inside of them one by
one
yes and so what you're starting to see
now is
i mean i get the messages on twitter and
linkedin all the time
hey i'm a banker by trade but i'm a
bitcoiner at heart
right and so what you're doing is you're
essentially infiltrating the
organizations
not in in physical uh you know uh
population
yeah but with the ideas and with the
philosophies
banker in the streets bitcoin are in the
sheets
[Laughter]
i like it uh with that said in terms of
posting and memes
i gotta say um like bring it on
because i believe
um in terms of asymmetry of power i
believe in
that love will save the world not memes
uh
or at least the good good vibe
memes as opposed to posting it's a
it's an interesting battleground though
it's an interesting battleground to
think about the other thing i would say
too
is um one of the elements uh that's
always
kind of funny to me is how much of the
entertainment
is love right so when you start to think
about how many of the memes that are
posted for example
are for outsiders versus insiders yes
laser eyes
right which seems absolutely ridiculous
elementary and
and uh frankly uh beneath anyone in any
level of power or influence
in the world somehow has congressmen and
senators who have done it yeah
they're not trying to uh convince their
colleagues
in uh elected positions to become
bitcoiners yeah they're speaking
directly internally to the bitcoin
community yeah
there's some sense in which yes memes is
love
even if you're hearing bitcoin is love
they're trying to convert me the one
that you
the you uh you have to laugh at right
probably my favorite one out of all of
it is i've seen on multiple occasions uh
you know mark cuban a couple of years
ago kevin o'leary whoever you know
wealthy people billionaires etc and you
have people on anonymous accounts who
knows who they are
telling them have fun staying poor
and it's just you know it's just again
part of a community and i think it it's
uh it's a feature not a bug
there's bad aspects to it at times but i
do think it's a net positive
it's just like the immune system it does
a lot of crappy stuff but overall
it's a it's a major net positive
you